- We don't score a touchdown every time,
but we move the ball forward.
John F. Kennedy didn't look up at the moon
and say aww, that's too far.
None of us can afford to be complacent.
Stuff gets better if we work at it.
It wasn't because of my
brilliance or something
that these things happened.
They spend time thinking about polls
but not about principle.
Nobody cares how tough
your upbringing was.
You can't take yourself too seriously,
you have to take the job seriously.
We get real exercise for about two weeks
and then we fall asleep for two years.
Winston Churchill was dismissed
as little more than a has-been
who enjoyed scotch a little bit too much.
- He's the 44th and current
president of the United States
and the first African
American to hold the office.
- He's a graduate of Columbia University
and Harvard Law School.
- He was inaugurated as
president on January 20th, 2009.
- He's Barack Obama
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
- We have looked at a
whole slew of problems
when we came into office.
And we've said, where can we
advance the ball down the field
each and every time, across the board.
And we don't score a touchdown every time,
but we move the ball forward.
- Do you feel like you've hit the metrics
that you wanted to hit, even within--
- You're always going to fall short
because if you're hitting your marks
that means you didn't
set them high enough.
That's what hope is, imagining,
and then fighting for,
and then working for
what did not seem possible before.
That's leadership.
John F. Kennedy didn't look up at the moon
and say aww, that's too far.
We can't go, false hopes.
Martin Luther King
didn't stand on the steps
of the Lincoln Memorial and say,
go home everybody, the
dream's deferred, false hopes.
Ya'll need a reality check.
(audience applauds)
There is a moment in the
life of every generation
when that spirit of hopefulness
has to come through,
if we are to make our mark on history.
We too often let the
external, the material things
serve as indicators that we're doing well,
even though something inside us tells us
that we're not doing our best.
That we're avoiding that which is hard,
but also necessary, that
we're shrinking from
rather than rising to the
challenges of the age.
And the thing is, in this
new hyper-competitive age,
none of us, none of us can
afford to be complacent.
That's true whatever
profession you choose.
Professors might earn
the distinction of tenure
but that doesn't guarantee that they'll
keep putting in the long
hours and late nights
and have the passion and the
drive to be great educators.
The same principle is true
in your personal life.
Being a parent is not just a
matter of paying the bills,
doing the bare minimum.
It's not just bringing a child
into the world that matters,
but the acts of love
and sacrifice it takes
to raise and educate that child,
and give them opportunity.
The one thing that I feel deeply about,
and this is something
I'll feel deeply about
when I leave government is,
stuff gets better if we work at it
and we stay focused on where we're going.
It doesn't immediately get all solved
and I warned against this
when I was running for office,
because everybody had the
hope posters and the this
and the that and everybody
was feeling like--
- Hey, we didn't make
those, you made those!
(audience laughing)
- No, no, no, no!
- What'dya blamin' us?
- No, no, no, no, no!
- That wasn't us.
- Hang on a second.
No, no, no, I like them.
- I'm pretty sure that came from you.
- It was a nice poster.
- All right.
- No, but what I'm saying is that,
if you look at what I said at the time,
I said, "This is going to
be an ongoing project".
And it's a project of citizens.
It's not just, fix it.
It's how do we work together
to get things done,
and it will be imperfect.
- [John] Yes.
- But, over time, is it better?
And here's the thing I can say, John.
- [John] Yes.
I can say this unequivocally.
The VA is better now than
when I came into office.
It is better now than
Government works better than
when I came into office.
The economy, by every metric, is better
than when I came into office.
And so, the reason I can sleep at night,
(audience applauding)
is I say to myself, you
know what, it's better.
Now, am I satisfied with it?
No, and should voters
be satisfied with it?
Absolutely not, because otherwise you know
if we get complacent and lazy
then stuff doesn't happen.
You just don't succeed
in any endeavor
unless you've got a team
that's been supporting you.
And, that's part of my
political philosophy.
It's really based on my own experience,
which was if somebody
hadn't been out there
looking out for me,
starting with my mom, my
grandmother, my grandfather,
then I wouldn't have made it.
It wasn't because of my
brilliance or something
that these things happened,
it had to do with people
investing in ya.
And so we've got to make
sure we're investing
in the next generation, just
like somebody invested in us.
I want to highlight two main problems
with that old, tired
me-first approach to life.
First of all, it distracts you
from what's truly important.
And it may lead you to
compromise your values
and your principles and your commitments.
Think about it.
It's in chasing titles and status
and worrying about the next election
rather than the national interests
and the interests of those who
you're supposed to represent
that politicians so often
lose their ways in Washington.
(audience applauding)
They spend time thinking about polls,
but not about about principle.
It was in pursuit of
gaudy short-term profits
and the bonuses that came with them,
that so many folks lost
their way on Wall Street,
engaging in extraordinary risks
with other people's money.
In contrast, the leaders we revere,
the businesses and institutions that last,
they are not generally the
result of a narrow pursuit
of popularity or personal advancement
but of devotion to some bigger purpose.
The preservation of the
Union, or the determination
to lift a country out of a depression.
The creation of a quality product.
A commitment to your
customers, your workers,
your shareholders, and your community.
A commitment to make
sure that an institution
like ASU is inclusive and diverse
and giving opportunity to all.
That's the hallmark
of real success.
We know that too many
young men in our community
continue to make bad choices.
And I have to say growing up,
I made quite a few myself.
Sometimes I wrote off my own failings
as just another example
of the world trying
to keep a Black man down.
I had a tendency
sometimes, to make excuses
for me not doing the right thing.
But one of the things that
all of you have learned
over the last four years
is there's no longer
any room for excuses.
(audience applauding)
I understand there's a
common Fraternity creed
here at Morehouse, "Excuses
are tools of the incompetent
"used to build bridges to nowhere
"and monuments of nothingness."
Well, we've got no time for excuses.
Not because the bitter legacy of slavery
and segregation have vanished
entirely, they have not.
Not because racism and discrimination
no longer exist, we know
those are still out there.
It's just that in today's hyper-connected,
hyper-competitive world with
millions of young people
from China and India and Brazil,
many of whom started with a whole lot less
than all of you did,
all of them entering the
global workforce alongside you,
nobody is going to give you anything
that you have not earned.
Nobody cares how tough
your upbringing was.
Nobody cares if you suffered
some discrimination.
And moreover, you have
to remember that whatever
you've gone through,
it pales in comparison
to the hardships previous
generations endured
and they overcame them.
And if they overcame them,
you can overcome them too.
Part of the way that
you survive the stress
of the White House
is being able to laugh with your team
about some of the crazy
stuff that happens.
And, you know, you can't
take yourself too seriously,
you have to take the job seriously.
You have to take your
responsibilities seriously.
But, you have to be able
to laugh at yourself
first and foremost in order
to be able to manage the whole thing.
You have to have a plan,
you have to have a strategy
and then you have to have stick-to-it-ness
because you know the strategy
is not going to immediately bear fruit.
The American character is one that lurches
between spasm and trance.
We get real exercise for about two weeks
and then we fall asleep for two years.
And what Charles Hamilton
Houston understood is
that our vision extends decades.
It extends generations.
And those young men I talked about,
we may not be able to
reach them right now,
but I tell you what,
if we set the trend lines
just a little bit better
then the infant that's crying in Compton
or Harlem, or Anacostia,
or the ninth ward,
that infant may have a different future.
And then when that infant
has a different future,
the country has a different future.
And then we as a people
have a different future.
So, there's got to be
an understanding of how
time can actually help us move mountains
if we're working with time,
we're not waiting for time,
we're working with it.
You may have setbacks
and you may have failures
but you're not done.
You're not even getting started.
Not by a long shot.
And if you ever forget
that, just look to history.
Thomas Paine was a failed
corset maker, a failed teacher
and a failed tax collector
before he made his mark on history
with a little book called, Common Sense
that helped ignite a revolution.
(audience applauding)
Julia Child didn't
publish her first cookbook
until she was almost 50.
Colonel Sanders didn't open up his first
Kentucky Fried Chicken
until he was in his 60s.
(audience laughing)
Winston Churchill was
dismissed as little more
than a has-been who enjoyed
scotch a little bit too much
before he took over as Prime Minister
and saw Great Britain
through it's finest hour.
No one thought a former football player
stocking shelves at the local supermarket
would return to the game he loved
to become a Super Bowl MVP
and then come here to Arizona
and lead your Cardinals
to their first Super Bowl.
(audience applauding)
Your body of work is never done.
Each of them at one point in their life
didn't have any title, or
much status to speak of.
But they had passion.
A commitment to following that passion
wherever it would lead
and to working hard
every step along the way.
- Thank you so much for watching.
We made this video because
Jerome A. asked us to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
- And please let us know
which of the top 10 rules
that you like the most,
please leave a comment below
and we will join in the discussion.
- Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
- Bye.